[Music]
angular seven is officially here and one
of its coolest new features is the
virtual scroll behavior in the component
development kit it allows you to easily
build a high-performance list that only
renders the items visible to the user in
today's video I'll show you everything
you need to know about virtual scroll
but we'll also take things a few steps
further by making an animated infinite
and real-time if you're new here like
and subscribe and I'm giving away some
winter swag with this video all you have
to do is leave a comment below and we'll
pick a winner on the live stream on
Wednesday so first of all what is
virtual scrolling and why would you want
to use it it's useful when you have a
large list of items to loop over but you
only want to render the items that are
visible in the viewport this should give
you much smoother performance when
working with big lists because the
browser only needs to render a small
subset of the data the cdk provides a
handful of components and directives to
make virtual scrolling super easy in
addition it provides a handful of tools
that makes it much easier to measure the
scrolled element which we can then use
to pull data from our back-end database
in batches giving us an infinite
real-time virtual scroll the first thing
you want to do is make sure you're
up-to-date with angular version 7 then
we can quickly add the cdk to our app by
running ng add angular material you'll
notice that when you do this in angular
7 it gives you a prompt to have
questions to go through you can just
select the defaults and then if you also
want to follow along with the firebase
part you'll want to install angular fire
at this point as well but I'm going to
start with just the cdk basics before we
get to that point if we jump over to my
app module you can see that I'm
importing the scrolling module from the
cdk and then I also have a couple of
components generated just for this demo
so you want to make sure that you have
the scrolling module here in the import
section and then optionally angularfire
for the back-end stuff now that we're
all set up let's start by looking at the
basics of virtual scroll the first thing
you'll need is a big list of something
to loop over so I want to show you how
to generate a ton of fake data really
quickly first I wrote my own helper
function that will return a random emoji
and then I installed the fakir j/s
library that we can use to generate fake
names and email addresses and stuff like
that then I'll set up a property of
people and then I'll define that
property as an array of 100 elements
then we can map each element
that array to an object with some fake
data so we'll give each object a name a
bio and an emoji so that gives us a big
array of items to loop over now we need
to go into the HTML and set up a context
for our virtual scroll we can do that by
just dropping in the cdk virtual school
viewport component it has one required
argument which is the item size or
height which is represented in pixels so
typically with a virtual scroll you want
items to have a fixed height if possible
so with that being said let's quickly
jump over to our CSS code you'll first
want to make sure that your viewport has
some height so in this case I'm having
it fill up the entire height of the
viewport then each item inside of my
viewport will have a fixed height of 100
pixels which matches the item size
argument in the component itself and
just for bonus points if you want to
make it look cool this is a good place
to customize the pseudo selector for the
actual scroll bar element to give it a
different style and size as the user
Scrolls down when inside the context of
a scroll viewport the cdk gives you a
structural directive called cdk virtual
for it replaces ng4 but it works exactly
the same way if we go ahead and serve
the app what's happening is that the cdk
is keeping track of the items in the
list and which items will fit into the
viewport a good way to demonstrate this
is just by using a plain CSS animation
because that animation will be applied
each time the item is rerender so I'm
using a little library here you may have
heard of called animate CSS and you'll
notice as I scroll up and down the
animation is reapplied to each element
because it's being rear-ended in the Dom
in a regular list the CSS animation
would only be applied on the initial
page load so that's kind of an
interesting little side effect with
virtual scroll that you can play with
now there's a couple of other basic
things that you need to know first of
all the virtual scroll component emits a
custom event called scrolled index
change eventually we'll use this to
implement our infinite scroll because it
emits the index of the item that the
user has scrolled to so we can use that
to determine when to pull the next batch
of items from the database then you'll
also notice that this component has its
own public API that we can use to do
things like measure the viewport or get
the total item list size or even
dynamically scroll to a specific element
in order to use those methods you'll
need to grab the component from the Dom
and you'll definitely want a strong type
it so will
import the cdk virtual school viewport
component and then we can grab it with
view child then we can set it up as a
property called viewport and if we start
typing this out you'll notice it shows
us a bunch of different methods that we
can use so that's how you can interact
with the component dynamically in your
typescript code for example if you have
some chat messages you could use this to
scroll directly to the bottom or update
the scroll position when new messages
are received now that you know the
basics we're ready to build out our
infinite real-time scroll using
firestore I created an infinite scroll
video with firestore a while back but
today's solution will improve upon it in
two big ways first of all it will make
the list real-time so even though we're
pulling items and batches they'll still
be updated in real time if the data
changes on the back end and the second
obvious improvement is that this will be
a virtual scroll so we should be able to
get much better performance as the user
Scrolls through more and more items and
also the cdk will just make our code
much more simple and reliable now
starting in the component type script
we'll first import angularfire store as
well as a bunch of different stuff here
from rxjs we'll pull items from the
database in batch sizes of 20 then we'll
set up a property for the viewport
itself and then one to determine whether
or not we've reached the end of the list
and then a behavior subject to keep
track of the offset that we'll use to
make our query to fire store and it's
important that the subject starts with
null and not undefined or an empty
string because we need that null value
to start our query to fire store so
every time this offset changes we're
going to want to make a new query to
fire store for the source data but we
only want to do that when the user
Scrolls to the bottom of the current
list so we can listen to that index
change event that I showed you earlier
and then we'll run this next batch
method which takes the event as well as
the very last item in the list as its
argument then if we've reached the end
then we'll just go ahead and return and
not pull any additional data but
otherwise we can take the viewport
rendered range end value and compare
that to the total items in the actual
list itself and conveniently the cdk has
a method for that called get data length
so if the ending index equals the total
length of the items in the array then we
know that we've reached the end we can
send the next offset value to our
behavior subject which will reactively
pull a new back
of items from the database and then
while I have you here I'm also going to
set up a track by function which just
tracks the index of the items in the
array and only renders the ones that
change that's just a good thing to have
for real-time data because otherwise the
entire list would rerender for each item
that changes so now I'm going to break
this down into manageable chunks the
first one is getting an individual batch
from the database and to do that we need
to know the last scene item in the
previous batch I've added 200 records to
firestore of the same dummy data that I
showed you earlier and I want to do a
paginate query on that data so first I
want to order by that user's name and
then we'll start after the offset value
which needs to be null if we're starting
a new batch
otherwise it needs to be the name of the
last user in the last batch and lastly
we'll limit our query to our batch size
which again is 20 from there we'll go
ahead and call snapshot changes to get
these documents snapshots as an
observable if this observable emits an
empty array then it's safe to assume
that we've reached the end of our
collection in the database at which
point we can set the end property to
true now the tricky part is keeping
everything up to date in real-time
across multiple batches in order to do
that reliably we need to take the array
of documents and then map them to an
object where the key is their document
ID this allows us to update a documents
data anywhere in the list based on its
key value instead of its index position
this ensures that every document in the
array is unique because otherwise we are
at risk of adding duplicate documents to
the array if things change between the
queries so the next thing we want to do
is go into our constructor and set up a
source observable that first listens to
the offset value and then merges and new
batches whenever the offset changes
which again will happen when the user
Scrolls to the bottom of the list that
event can be fired multiple times so I'm
going to throttle it by 500 milliseconds
just so we're not sending off redundant
requests to the backend now you'll
notice that I'm using merge map here to
merge a new batch into the stream it's
important to use merge map here and not
switch map because otherwise the
previous subscriptions would be canceled
meaning that only the very last batch
would be real-time from there we can
pipe in the scan operator which will
just
merge in the current batch with the
existing batches so this batch map
observable is our main source of truth
because it contains all the mappings for
the individual item keys and their data
but we still want an actual array to
loop over in the front end so we can go
here and define our actual infinite
array of objects as this batch map but
map to the object values which will give
us an array of objects and that takes
care of the main logic for our infinite
real-time virtual scroll that may have
seemed relatively complex but in the
grand scheme of things it's very simple
considering what it does now we just
have a couple of small modifications in
the HTML if you want to show an index in
your list you can just say let I equals
index and then we'll also add in our
track by function that we defined
earlier then we can listen to that
scrolled index change event and the
first argument will be the event itself
which is the index number then the
second argument is the offset value for
the query which in our case will be the
name of the very last person in the
array we can actually just parse that
value right here in the template not the
prettiest code in the world but it works
then the last thing we need to do is
unwrap the infinite observable my
preferred way of doing this is using an
NG container and then unwrapping the
observable with the async pipe we can
then say as people to give us a template
variable of the array of objects and
then we can just use it throughout this
HTML now if we pull up the demo you can
see that we have all of our objects here
in the database and they're queried in
the same alphabetical order that we get
when we order them on the firebase
console and if we make any changes to
our data on the right it'll be reflected
in the UI on the left in real time it is
important to keep in mind that the
actual position of the item won't change
and if it's deleted it won't be removed
from the list but if you need that
functionality that could definitely be
made possible with some additional work
in the code now I am pulling up the
browser console and you'll notice that
there's an array being console logged on
the right every time we get to a certain
event the array size initially starts at
20 and then as we scroll down it will
change the offset and our array grows
from 20 to 40 to 60 and so on and from
the users perspective it happens so fast
that it looks like this list existed all
along which is exactly what you want
with an infinite scroll
but we are keeping track when we get to
the end of the list so when we finally
reach that point we'll go ahead and give
the user some indication that there are
no items left to retrieve that's all
folks if this video helps you please
like and subscribe and if you want to
take your development to the next level
consider becoming a pro member at
angular firebase comm you'll get access
to all kinds of exclusive content like
full courses and my book designed to
help you build and ship your app faster
thanks for watching and I'll talk to you
soon